foreign
Ruth joins us in Los Angeles California
Ruth how can we help
hi I'm
I'm at a life stage where I've come
through a lot of transition my my
husband passed away uh three years ago
and
um what happened over the course of time
is he passed away and in the course I I
took on our properties and that sort of
thing so I
inherited wealth or took over the family
business that part of it
and um
I lost a lot oh actually like all family
friends and I've had family try to sue
me for part of his estate and I'm in a
place where I just need new friends and
I'm looking for people that have wealth
and are interested in using it to reach
out and make an impact and help others
but I don't know where to go for that
sort of thing wow
well first of all you've been through a
lot and yeah that's tough and uh you do
need those people and and you need
friends you have you did I hear you say
you lost your friends
oh yeah well yeah I mean
I lost my best friend she died the year
before my husband died so but also what
happened is all of a sudden friends
expected me to be
give them money or make things throw
them parties that sort of thing it got
it got weird yeah because I saw you come
into a lot of wealth and then they got
real attached
uh yeah and so I mean I literally had to
cut
basically everybody out
um
well I'm sorry you've been through that
and and I I will tell you though I think
you do know where these people are you
know so you're in the Los Angeles area
um you are
uh still running the company I'm
guessing
um yeah yeah I mean you I don't it
pretty much you know it pretty much runs
itself I'm basically retired I don't
really need to do very much
before my husband passed as well so
first thing I want you doing is I have
something I'm sorry I just want you
here's what I want you to do I want you
to start joining some social activities
where you know quite frankly let's just
be really honest where other wealthy
women are going to be
because now now they don't need you for
anything
and you're going to find some
like-minded souls and people who
understand you and they're not you know
they're just friends with you they just
want to play tennis with you or they
want to play bunker or they don't want
anything they don't want anything other
than just it's a social thing so I mean
this is as simple as you know local
country clubs and and Social Clubs and
like you got to get out and meet people
and the only way to meet people is to
get in those places where those people
are congregating and there's nothing
wrong with that you know the old phrase
birds of a feather flock together well
you know where those people are flocking
yes or no
I why would I be calling you or if that
would know I think you're calling for I
think you're calling for ideas which I'm
giving you ideas but you know where
those people are where in the Los
Angeles area do you live give me give me
the uh the neighborhood or the the area
of Los Angeles
it's like Manhattan Beach Manhattan
Beach okay great lovely area okay so are
there country clubs in in the Manhattan
Beach area
um yeah okay so that's a that's a big
dollar thing I know hold on we're
brainstorming all right so it's not a
country club but you live in a
neighborhood where it's right it's got
an HOA
a little bit with the HOA yeah yeah so
there's Facebook groups probably in your
community there's probably multiple for
different social groups I mean I'm in a
small neighborhood and we've got a ton
of them and so I would start connecting
go to the HOA meetings just to meet
people in the neighborhood because
likely they are on the same level of
wealth in a in a general way as you and
then you start joining those Facebook
groups and find figure out what hobbies
you want to connect with people over or
do you have things that you like to do
for fun
yeah I mean I just like what you guys
were saying in the break I mean I love
reading I love writing I like hiking and
that sort of thing I have a disabled
family member that lives with me my son
and that limits the amount of time I
have for you to to go out engage yeah so
I I do have a but yeah
I I still even in the neighborhood I run
into situations where people are asking
a lot of financial questions and that is
that that's uncomfortable you mean like
they're asking you for money
no they're asking me how much I sold my
house for they're asking me how much the
repairs on my house I mean I don't
normally
I don't know I don't expect to be having
those kind of conversations with people
that are friends it would be more like
you know how's your mom or how was your
trip your vacation or that sort of thing
um well again so I mean I appreciate
George jumping in and I appreciate what
you're saying but you you do know where
wealthy people are spending time you do
you simply do I don't know Manhattan
Beach like you know Manhattan Beach but
you know in surrounding areas I mean you
you've got more Hobbies than just
reading and writing now you are limited
and I think this is part of the problem
or I should say challenge because of
your son I mean that's a challenge for
you just don't have a ton of time so
you've got to make the most of that time
and so whether it be book clubs in
certain areas but I mean you know where
are wealthy people people that are
successful that again aren't clingy and
aren't looking for anything from you
other than just the enjoyment of
relationship and a shared hobby or
shared interest that's what you've got
to do you make a list of your interests
and where are people hanging out and
you're in a very wealthy area so it's
not going to be hard to run into those
people but it is it is going to be some
intentionality like George said uh on
certain maybe groups and and talking
around the neighborhood and then you
know listen it depends on how much of
this the rest of your life this this
wants to be a big deal you've got a lot
of money if you need to move to a better
area you know I mean this is the stuff
life is made of you can't do this alone
you don't want to be alone and you need
this and so you need to make moves to
put yourself around those people
it's just you deciding it's time and
here's a challenge Ruth what if you
started the book club and you posted in
your neighborhood Facebook group and
said hey I'm going to have people over
once a week here's what we're doing let
me know if you want to join that happens
all the time and it's a great way when
you're the initiator amazing things
happen yeah I love that idea
okay so just put yourself out there it's
gonna be a little scary it's you know as
you get older like less likely to want
to put yourself out there but uh you
know as you just go grocery shopping or
where you're out and about make
conversation with people